see believe nation take notes okay this
is the wildest creature of all right
here
[Music]
what's a belief nation happy day two of
our Montreal adventure I just woke up
and I'm taking the team out before we go
off for our adventurous day
look who join me it's Nina look who else
it is it's Hayden
we're gonna start today yeah we're gonna
go get a different bagel different place
than last time the chocolate bagel had
fruit candy in it who puts fruit candy
with the chocolate bagel free candy who
candy if I have if I had my own country
through candy would be against the law
[Laughter]
we're gonna hit a farmers market big
market in Montreal then we're gonna hit
up the other bagel place that is
hopefully better and then explore some
more so let's go
okay first stop is Tim Hortons Nina
wanted some coffee but it's raining
so we're hustling Peyton want some water
you doing some coffee
Ben it's raining so let's go go go
Hayden got a hot chocolate and hot very
hot but really good we got our drinks
cheers Cheers
Shane's happy next up the market market
jumps something popular market here in
Quebec and we'll see what's here they
have maybe some food maybe some crafts
we're gonna explore
[Music]
ashay ash agent alone usually this is a
big outdoor thing too but since it's
cold so we'll just do the indoor part
you know likes trying new things
especially this food that's attached to
it so right Nina
what yeah you look like a big snowman
from behind
[Music]
oh I see soup take it home
cuts them tonight yeah I'm gonna get
some this is lentils carrots and potato
with [ __ ] cards carrots at least about
the college's vegetables
until Dontos come back okay
we've been eating non-stop junk since
we've been here so Nina's excited to
have something healthy today
let's Tory brought it to the farmers
market whatever you want if it brings a
smile to Nina's face and we're gonna do
it
sharing Oh cherry 's okay well we don't
have to bite you Fe Nina
you're prettier than all these flowers
combined alright come on
you see believe they shouldn't take
notes okay
lots of options for Nina I think she's
gonna go back and get some of that soup
though her tonight
fudge is great if I wasn't eating so
much junk I would get some of that but
just go Quebec fudge is really quality
[Music]
I look at this little microphone a más
difícil sweet ah Nina you're my mini
banana use the believed nation mini
banana
[Music]
all right we bought all of our groceries
now what soup mean I just can't avoid a
soup now the question is what kind of
soup carrot soup lentil soup vegetable
soup I think she's gonna go with carrots
you want to try some maple syrup I'll do
the favor how is it yummy okay we're
back to the soup place that could mean
his faces she's looking at the rise
berry maple syrup please what do you
think believe the agency we get him some
raspberry maple syrup okay let's get
Nina's soup person we can go back and
get you some
all right we're buying lots of stuff
today
good idea to come here what then maybe I
don't know if we should be buying i
hitting on my wife here in front of me
in a different language okay
good maybe we should be spending money
with him Nina is carrying some serious
bag Nina you're building your muscles
there we're going out that way
bicep curls curls Nina let's go girls
all right so that's the market we got
some yummy food we got some maple syrup
everybody's happy now we're gonna go to
the other famous bagel shop that
hopefully has better bagels I feel like
it shouldn't be that hard to to beat the
first place I was expecting a big
competition but I feel like it's gonna
be it well you know what it could be
even if this place sucks right so we'll
see I'm gonna put the camera away and
help the wife carry all those bags see
that I'm gonna put this away help
procure the bags and we're gonna get our
new bagels let's go
all right we are here we are closed we
are praying for some good yummy bagels
feel like this is it yeah
the Maison de bagel the big old house oh
there's a lineup that's a good sign
[Music]
let's eat some Vegas nina also got some
salmon cream cheese smoked salmon cream
cheese I'm excited
so we came to a Starbucks to eat our
bagels what do you want something to
drink
yeah well tea okay you set up the bagels
how cool get our drinks okay I got my
coffee
Gina's name is working on her tea and
most importantly we got our bagels
okay let's try way better than the other
you can OD tell me all right first by
the can you like take a bite
it's the same you know it's better for
Hayden all right looks like st. viateur
the Maison de bagel
it's the best one in Montreal all right
rain is coming down we enjoyed our
bagels next stop we're going to Olympic
Stadium where they had the Olympics
maybe baseball team coming back we'll
see there's a big Tower we're going to
go out then there's an attached bio dome
and a whole bunch of things to do that
is indoors I think which is good because
it's coming down hard and we're gonna
wrap up our second day in Montreal dirty
yeah let's go
[Music]
so this is a cool area where they have
the Olympic Stadium Tower and a bio dome
and a planetarium all together it's
raining and super cloudy so we're gonna
hit the tower at the end so hopefully we
could see more of the ring clears up
first stop is the bio dome where Nina
and Hayden will engage in epic bio
battles do to do to do to do not joke
I'm gonna have some fun
what did the flower say to the bee buzz
uh you can go inside and tell the
flowers and the bees
[Music]
oh no food or drink allowed I gotta
finish this very large copy quickly all
right we're going in Hayden hurt himself
you pulled a muscle you want to sit down
okay
up first is the tropical rainforest
[Music]
Nina you don't like the bats you hate
that
how about Batman I'm Batman what are you
doing you're hiding up there
[Music]
this is the wildest creature of all
right here
Oh as an alligator or crocodile one of
the tooth
the big character now the maple forest
nice and cool in here
[Music]
you're just running through Gulf of st.
Barts
[Music]
look at that duck all right I like the
cool air in here
[Music]
subpolar regions we're gonna see some
penguins I think
look who's hatching this hatch another
today Wow look at all the puffins huh
look at all the puffins those are lots
of puffins yeah okay that's it for the
biodome what do we think guys you want
to go through it again okay hey didn't
eat some food and then we're gonna hit
maybe the stadium maybe something else
we'll see
[Music]
[Music]
all right we're gonna go to the top of
that is a world record for what it's all
in French
can we go to the other side also in
French okay let me try to translate then
world record to the Olympic Stadium in
Montreal for what the tallest thing
cousin they almost something in the
world
ich Lina is on a leaning tower tallest
leaning tower in the world I think well
this is English out here oh my god okay
let's see what's that close the tallest
man-made leaning tower in the Munch yeah
anyway that's where we're going to the
top
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we took some nice glamour shots got some
good angles and what did hayden get as a
souvenir olympic stadium nice all right
time to catch the ride back down what
are you doing Hayden's running in
circles
Nina's watching old Teemo videos what do
you think excite me for going out this
one unit doesn't she waits she watches
Teemo videos we love her all right let's
go thank you
here we go alright we're done you guys
have fun